i think we've got to see that a riot
is the language of the unheard
to justify the violent tactics of some
of the protesters in the demonstrations
that have swept the country over the
past week martin luther king jr's famous
line
has been circulating once again last
saturday
king's own son posted it to twitter but
that quote has been widely
misinterpreted
because it's taken out of context
non-violence
is the most potent weapon available to
the negro in his struggle for freedom
and justice
i think for the negro to turn to
violence
would be both impractical
and immoral king sought to make his
position crystal
clear in his 1966 interview with 60
minutes mike wallace
i would hope that we can avoid riots
because riots are self-defeating and
socially destructive king considered
violent protests to be self-defeating
because as he argued in 1968
every time a riot develops it makes a
right-wing takeover more likely
and helps the segregationist george
wallace the violent clashes over the
last week have already created a
backlash with 58
of respondents to a recent poll saying
they support the use of military force
please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite
and peaceful journalists such as cnn's
chris cuomo and recent pulitzer prize
winner nicole hannah jones have
downplayed the seriousness of property
destruction and violence by some
protesters
violence is when an agent of the state
kneels on a man's neck until
all of the life is leeched out of his
body destroying property which can be
replaced
is not violent but political leaders in
some of the communities where the
property destruction has taken place
have shown that it's possible both to
acknowledge the horrors of police
brutality while at the same time
denouncing theft violence and
destruction
these people did this for no reason
it's not gonna bring george back here
george is in a better place than we are
this is not in the spirit of martin
luther king jr
this is chaos a protest has
purpose when dr king was assassinated we
didn't do this
to our city like king the best political
and civil rights leaders of the 1960s
were able both to condemn rioting
and to acknowledge the legitimacy of the
grievances that brought protesters into
the streets in the first place
new york mayor john lindsay soothed
racial tensions following king's 1968
assassination by calmly walking the
streets of harlem with other civil
rights leaders and reminding the public
of the fallen leaders unwavering
opposition to violence
the city's current mayor bill de blasio
has lacked the courage to forcefully
condemn both rioting and vandalism
and the violent tactics of his own
police force
minnesota officials initially deflected
blame for the riots onto outside
infiltrators before the press
exposed their misinformation and
president trump hid in a bunker and
tweeted out incendiary messages about
the coming show of force against the
rioters
if a city or state refuses to take the
actions that are necessary to defend the
life and property
of their residents then i will deploy
the united states military
and quickly solve the problem for them
politicians like atlanta mayor kisha
bottoms have said the ultimate answer
lies at the ballot box if you want
change in america go and register to
vote
do it in november while voting for
candidates who support policing and
criminal justice reform could have a
marginal impact in the long run
protesters are demanding immediate
action when police harass
and assault protesters they should be
held accountable through anti-chokehold
bills
and by putting an end to the legal
doctrine that protects them from
criminal prosecution
the internet has further decentralized
activism which has made today's protests
less uniform than ever before in the
final analysis
a riot is the language of the unheard
when king said this he wasn't excusing
riots but imploring those watching them
unfold
in horror to acknowledge the unjust
conditions that contributed to their
emergence
in the first place certain conditions
continue to exist in our society
which must be condemned as vigorously
as we condemn riots with no martin
luther king jr of our own
we all bear the burden more so of
condemning the initiation of violence
no matter the perpetrator no matter the
cause